gemeinsam mit nobelpreisträger matthias
n hat sie wegweisende theorien für das
entwicklungsprogramm der uno erarbeitet
gerechtigkeit war für sie stets ein
zentrales thema und gefühle
jetzt bringt sie beides zusammen und
behauptet ohne gefühle lässt sich keine
politik machen
martha nussbaum herzlich willkommen
schön dass sie hier sind
es freut mich dass in ihrer sendung zu
sein
wunderbar gerechtigkeit gefühle politik
eine große frage aber wie hängt das
zusammen
ich gehe davon aus dass die menschen
sehr egoistisch sind und sieht nur
wenige dinge wirklich wichtig aber aus
gründen der gerechtigkeit sind wir
aufgefordert uns für leute einzusetzen
denen wir nie begegnet sind
die wir nicht kennen wenn wir also
sozialhilfe projekte unterstützen die es
um der gerechtigkeit willen braucht
müssen wir uns umeinander kümmern und
menschen helfen auch wenn wir sie nicht
kennen
was also stützt zwingen der
gerechtigkeit prinzipien das ist meine
frage
dabei fokussiere ich auf zwei probleme
das erste problem ist die ökonomische
gerechtigkeit was bringt uns dazu geld
und steuern für die sozialhilfe zu
zahlen
das zweite problem ist die ethnische und
religiöse gerechtigkeit was bringt uns
dazu menschen unterschiedlicher ethnien
die gleichen rechte einzuräumen und
gefühle wie hass und abneigung zu
bekämpfen
wir brauchen also ein politisches
programm das sich mit emotionen befasst
das liebevolle gefühle fördert und hass
und abneigung unterbindet verschiedenen
fragen alle diskutieren aber zuerst noch
einmal vielleicht wirklich zu den engen
zusammenhang zwischen emotionen und der
politik hier im moment diskutiert man
sehr viel darüber dass man erfahren hat
anfangs dezember dass die bush
administration grausame foltermethoden
angeordnet hat nach nine eleven die
würden dann beschädigt als erweiterte
verhörmethoden
diesen zusammenhang haben natürlich
gefühle eine rolle gespielt die haben
die politik motiviert es war aber
wahrscheinlich so etwas wie hass rache
gefühle
ist es nicht ein bisschen naiv zu sagen
politik und gefühle sollten
zusammengebracht werden
schauen sie für jedes ziel in der
politik ob gut oder schlecht müssen die
menschen über ihre gefühle motiviert
werden und natürlich wissen wir alle
dass wir schlechte ziele wie hass gegen
gewissen ihren und folter
die gefühle der menschen manipuliert
werden man argument ist auch gute ziele
werden über gefühle erreicht wenn wir
denken wir könnten einfach sagen gut von
jetzt an haben wir eine
krankenversicherung ohne die leute mit
liebe und anteilnahme dafür zu gewinnen
wird so etwas nie zustande kam
im laufe der geschichte haben gute
politiker wie franklin roosevelt mit dem
new deal und kann den indien sehr
bewusst die gefühle der menschen
beeinflusst um gleichheit und einheit zu
fördern
auch martin luther king junior über ihn
gibt es übrigens einen schönen film der
gerade in den kinos angelaufen ist
da können es alle sehen wenn er sich an
jenem tag in washington erhoben und nur
gesagt hätte nun lasst uns gerechtigkeit
üben wären wir heute nirgendwo
er inspirierte die menschen in dem eher
poetische worte fand für seine vision
einer welt die schöner und besser war
als die welt in der sie liebten die
leute waren dafür empfänglich er wusste
wie er sie erreichen konnte
und da er sie mit einer liebe berührte
waren sie bereit ihre wut und ihren hass
zu überwinden und seine vision zu frauen
absolut einigen dingen aber gleichzeitig
ist es so dass wir im moment in europa
große probleme haben mit neuen formen
von nationalismus die rechtskonservative
seite bedient genau diese art von
sprache heimatgefühle die aufkommen die
besungen werden
das hat ja auch eine gefährliche seite
natürlich stimmt das das sehen wir schon
seit langem
sie kennen die geschichte aber die
intellektuellen der weimarer republik
sagten reagieren wir auf die schlechten
gefühle mit ruhe und analyse das war ein
fehler
sie hätten diesen gefühlen auch mit
symbolen kunst und liebe entgegen treten
sollen
das taten sie aber nicht sie haben die
herzen der menschen nicht berührt im
kampf gegen die negativen auswüchse des
nationalismus und gegen die damit
verbundenen schlechten gefühle müssen
wir schauen wie wir gute gefühle als
instrumente einsetzen können
natürlich müssen sie mit rationalen
argumenten einhergehen und wir müssen
kritik und einwände zu lassen
das ist ein wichtiger punkt in meinem
buch wie können wir das erreichen
wie können wir eine auf gefühlen
basierende politik betreiben die offen
ist für sokratische argumente und dialog
es ist möglich ein beispiel als kann die
mit millionen menschen an die küste
indiens marschierte um illegal salz zu
gewinnen und so den britischen
herrschern die stirn zu bieten musste er
natürlich die massen für seine sache
gewinnen denn die menschen gingen große
risiken ein
sie mussten ihre angst überwinden um
gandhis leidenschaftlicher forderung
nach freier nachzukommen
aber er wollte aus ihnen auch gute
mitglieder einer liberalen gesellschaft
machen auf dem weg zur küste sagen sie
ein lied von rabindranath tagore wenn
niemand einen rufer nimmt die allein
allein
wenn niemand an licht hochhält
ein entzündetes an deinen rippen und
brenner allein
natürlich ist es ein seltsamer gedanke
dass eine million gemeinsam marschieren
der menschen so ein lied singt doch das
wollte er leidenschaftliche solidarität
mit individueller freiheit und
kritikfähigkeit verbinden
genau das müssen wir tun schauspielerin
werden wollten sie haben ja auch eine
weile an schauspiel studiert sie können
das perfekt rezitieren woher kommt
eigentlich ihre liebe zu indien sie
zitieren ja ganz oft parcours
und auch überhaupt beispiel aus indien
sind sehr präsent in ihren büchern nun
ich habe lange für den indischen
philosophie matthias henn gearbeitet und
die feldstudien unseres projekts führten
wir in indien durch
deshalb reiste ich dorthin und verliebte
mich in das land ich lernte auch die
tradition von tagoe kennen
tagore waren große philosoph und einer
der größten denker die sich mit dem
problem der politischen emotionen
befasst haben und er bediente sich
populärer musik er schrieb 2000 lieder
über geschwisterlichkeit und widerstand
ja auch heute noch sehr beliebt sind
zwei davon dienten indien bzw
bangladesch als nationalem aber er
gründete auch eine schule und brachte
seinen schülern bei freie bürger zu sein
und zwar über den körper mittels tanz
matthias zens mutter war eine der
wichtigsten tänzerinnen an der schule
sie arbeitet eng mit al gore zusammen
und schrieb auch im buch über ihn als
tänzer und tanzlehrer ich habe sie
gekannt
ich war mit ihr befreundet und wir
sprachen oft über dieses thema das
berührte mich sehr für mich ist er einer
der interessantesten philosophen des
frühen zwanzigsten jahrhunderts aber
wurde nicht beachtet deshalb stets ein
philosophischer beitrag im zentrum eines
buchs sie betonen immer wieder und haben
jetzt auch jetzt getan wie wichtig
rhetorik ist in der politik eben auch
emotionen mitgefühl
im moment gibt es aber eine politische
figur in form eines schauspielers der
für sehr viel aufruhr sorgt denn viele
sehr sehr gerne sehen das ist kevin
spacey in der fernsehserie house of
cards und das ist keine figur die mit
viel mitgefühl agiert sondern im
gegenteil sehr sehr kalt ist schauen wir
uns doch gemeinsam einen ausschnitt an
wir sollten wundertäter in ihrer vita
aufnehmen frank macht sich gut als
zaubertrick aber das leben wir erheblich
leichter wenn der bastard gar nicht
gestorben wäre
der präsident wir beinahe explodiert
aber ich habe ihn beruhigt ich sagte
keine sorge frank macht das schon ist
das so ich mein' kann vorwurf dass sie
doppelt ist ein rennen so funktioniert
politik sie sollten sich nur nicht den
straßen also wenn sie denken
der herrgott vergibt ein gute nacht
[Musik]
und diese figur des franzis underwood
ist extrem kalt derzeit selten gefühle
und auch die beziehung zu seiner frau
ist eigentlich so gestrickt dass man
denkt das ist primär sehr viel
berechnung vorhanden kann ein solcher
politiker real erfolgreich sein
demokratie ist in keinerlei hinsicht
eine perfekte regierungsform die bürger
werden manchmal an der nase herumgeführt
aber selten auf diese weise so müssen
zum beispiel politiker die in den usa
präsident werden wollen mit den menschen
in verbindung treten können
das kann mit großen nazismus einhergehen
wir könnten den ich kennengelernt habe
ist eine sehr narzisstische
persönlichkeit er will von allen geliebt
werden
gleichzeitig kann er mit menschen in
kontakt treten
das ist eine gabe er weiß worunter
menschen leiden
er interessiert sich wirklich für sie
auch jetzt wo er seine stiftung betreibt
es gibt auch andere unvollkommene
politiker wie lebten johnson
er hatte viele mängel aber er zeigte
großes verständnis für ethnische
ungerechtigkeiten und verband sich
dadurch mit den bürgern
gleichzeitig konnte er sie eiskalt
manipulieren damit sie für die gesetze
stimmten die er durchsetzen wollte das
war ein widerwärtiger zug
aber er hatte auch eine starke
emotionale visionäre seite ich denke
diese mischung ist bei politikern eher
anzutreffen als eine kälte man sagt ja
oft eigentlich solche fernsehserien
machen die politik fast schon sehr sehr
viele leute gucken sie es wird viel
aufgegriffen was passiert in der welt in
form von fernsehserien selber
fernsehteam das tue ich nicht diese
serie aber ich schaue oft krimiserien zb
und orgel am liebsten in ableger special
victims unit
ich liebe die serie vor allem weil darin
so viel mitgefühl gezeigt wird mitgefühl
für die opfer der verbrechen aber auch
für polizeibeamte und andere
denn sie sind sehr einsam und müssen den
schwierigen situationen für
gerechtigkeit kämpfen
das berührt mich sehr gehen wir zurück
zu diesen gefühlen die die politik
eigentlich motivieren sie sagen in ihrem
neuen buch politische emotionen eines
der stärksten politischen gefühle dass
wir haben nicht der patriotismus und es
eigentlich der dreh und angelpunkt des
buches wir müssen eben wieder lernen in
einer guten art und weise patriotisch zu
sein
was ist für sie ein gesunder guter papa
ein gesunder patriotismus muss in erster
linie gute ziele anstreben
die gleichheit und ein menschenwürdiges
leben beinhalten und nicht hass
stigmatisierung und ungleichheit
er muss auch die idee der freien kritik
beinhalten auf die eine oder andere
weise muss man die menschen ermutigen
nicht nur gute ziele anzustreben sondern
unabhängig zu sein und selbstständig zu
denken
im buch erzähle ich wie selber zum
ersten mal mit patriotismus konfrontiert
wurde
als ich sechs jahre ich verlasse ich die
wahre geschichte eines mädchens das
während des amerikanischen
unabhängigkeitskriegs große risiken auf
sich nahm
es wird nachts durch eine gefährliche
gegend und warnte die amerikanischen
rebellen vor den anrückenden
sie war erst 15
ich war tief beeindruckt dieses mädchen
kämpfte für die freiheit das inspirierte
mich sehr vor allem weil es ein mädchen
war
ich konnte mich mit ihm identifizieren
und spürte wie sehr sie den
freiheitskampf liebte und sich für den
fall des britischen empires einsetzte
diese geschichte fühlte mich auf und
machte mich auch mit grundlegenden
politischen themen vertraut
ich denke das war ein gesunder
patriotismus den müssen wir weiter geben
in vereinfachter form an junge menschen
in komplexer form an erwachsene
und wenn wir sehen dass unsere ziele
mangelhaft sind müssen wir sie
überdenken
rincon schrieb in seiner rede des burger
dress die us geschichte neu indem er
sagte es gehe einzig ungleichheit
niemand vor ihm hatte dass jesu
ausgedrückt er sah den kampf gegen die
sklaverei als fortsetzung der
wichtigsten erkenntnisse der
gründerväter amerikas das vertrat er so
eindrücklich dass ihm alle glaubten ich
kann mir sehr gut vorstellen dass
patriotismus wichtig ist für den
zusammenhalt einer gesellschaft
vielleicht auch um die soziale
gerechtigkeit voranzutreiben innerhalb
einer gemeinschaft aber ein ganz
wichtiges thema ist ja auch inwiefern
ihren patriotismus ausgrenzen wirken
kann und wir haben vorhin schon kurz
darüber gesprochen das problem dass
patriotismus ableiten kann ich einen
fremdenfeindlichen nationalismus und das
ist eigentlich ein thema das sie
aufnehmen in diesem buch die neue
religiöse intoleranz
sie haben sehr sehr hart kritisiert was
passiert ist mit dem burka verboten also
burka verbot in belgien frankreich
italien haben sie gesagt geht das gar
nicht
auch das minarett verbot in der schweiz
kritisieren sie in diesem buch
ausführlich
sie sagen in den usa wäre das nie
möglich gewesen warum nicht
es ist nicht so dass wir keine probleme
hätten
unser hauptproblem ist der rassismus
religiöse intoleranz weniger zuerst
einmal ist die usa eine nation von
immigranten jeder us bürger ist ein
einwanderer
jeder ist einer dominanten
religionsgemeinschaft entflohen um
religiöse freiheit zu erlangen
die fähigkeit zu verstehen dass menschen
raum brauchen um ihre religion auf ihre
weise auszudrücken erlangten wir also
sehr natürlich und sehr früh becker
weigerten sich zum beispiel im gericht
ihren hut abzunehmen
das galt als unangebracht und respektlos
aber alle dachten na gut das ist ihre
religion
sie müssen ermutigt werden ihren eigenen
weg zu gehen
das ist eine amerikanische tradition
zwei us amerikaner ausmacht ist nicht
eine besondere sprache eine eigene art
sich zu kleiden eine besondere religion
oder ethnie sondern gewisse politische
prinzipien wie indien australien oder
kanada haben die usa ein
politische auffassung ihre identität und
das macht es viel einfacher
neueinwanderer zu akzeptieren ich denke
europa hatte lange eine romantische
vorstellung von identität die auf blut
boden und sprache gründet da ist es viel
schwieriger jemanden mit dunklerer haut
als zugehörig zu betrachten europa
empfängt diese menschen weiß dann aber
nicht genau wie sisi integrieren soll
[Musik]
ich verstehe sehr gut dass sie meinen
nun gleichzeitig artig genau an diesem
punkt auch gewisse schwierigkeiten sie
zu verstehen und ich bin froh wenn sie
sind wir erklären
an einem gewissen punkt sagen sie ja
genau das eigentliche problem ist in
europa das die nation aufatmen aufgebaut
sind aber gerade die schweiz ist ein
beispiel für dass das nicht stimmt die
schweiz ist eine so genannte gesinnungs
nation eigentlich sehr ähnlich wie das
was habermas den verfassungspatriotismus
genannt hat und genau den kritisieren
sie ja sie sagen ja eigentlich
verfassungspatriotismus das reicht nicht
gesehen aktion das ist zu dünn
da kann man eigentlich nicht wirklich
ein patriotismus entwickeln der eben gut
und stark ist aber gerade wir haben
keine solche ethnische verbundenheit wir
haben vier landessprachen wir sind
eigentlich ein zusammen gewürfeltes funk
und trotzdem gab es diese
minarett-initiative oder gibt es das ist
eine sehr interessante frage und ich
müsste wohl einige zeit hier leben um
eine gute antwort geben zu können
aber die studenten an der universität
sagten mir gestern hat wir darüber
diskutierte forderung dass wir in der
schweiz schaffen eine art von einheit in
dem wir alle anderen fernhalten obwohl
wir selbst verschiedene sprachen
sprechen oder verschiedenen ethnien
angehören real so groß sind die
unterschiede nicht in dem heißen
schweizer sind ja christ was sie auch
von nationalstaaten unterscheidet sie
gehören zusammen durch ihren kampf um
unabhängigkeit und indem sie andere
menschen fernhalten
dadurch fällt es viel schwerer menschen
zu akzeptieren die ins land kommen nicht
der eu beizutreten ist ein zeichen dafür
und die schwierigkeiten mit immigranten
sie haben also recht wenn sie sagen dass
die ursachen die zu intoleranz führen in
der schweiz andere sind als in finnland
oder in anderen teilen europas aber am
ähnlich ist dieses misstrauen gegenüber
andersartigen dass die menschen zusammen
schweißt das zeigt sich darin dass man
immigranten ins land lässt weil man sie
aus arbeits gründen braucht aber mann
heißt sie nicht wirklich willkommen
sie diskutiert haben mit leuten hier in
bern wir sind hier in bern zu haben hier
gegenwärtig die einstein lag schaffte
gegeben
das heißt es in den kontakt mit den
menschen denen ihr fragen fragen stellen
was mich interessiert ist einfach immer
noch diese frage was wir eigentlich mit
diesem patriotismus anfangen können weil
grundsätzlich würde ich sagen das heißt
wenn ich patriotische gefühle habe und
ich kenne solche gefühle auch ich bin
zum beispiel ein großer fan von
schweizer liedgut finde es wunderbar
diese unterschiedlichen dialekte in der
schweiz oder wenn ich von bern nach
lausanne fahre und es eröffnet sich mir
der blick über den genfer see dann kann
ich nicht anders aus innerlich zu
schauen und auch einen kleinen moment
vielleicht stolz zu sein bürgerinnen
dieses finde ich sehr sehr schönen
landes zu sein aber wenn ich
gleichzeitig nicht fürchte vor fremden
dingen falls ich das tun würde dann weiß
ich nicht ob mir der patriotismus helfen
würde das fremde zu integrieren ob ich
nicht viel mehr sagen würde gerade auch
als philosophin was jedoch auch
eigentlich brauchen ist respekt
voreinander
ich denke respekt ist zu schwach und zu
dünn um menschen zu motivieren probleme
zu bekämpfen
sie können sagen ich respektiere diese
armen menschen aber ich gebe ihnen kann
geld oder natürlich respektiere ich
afroamerikaner aber warum sollte ich sie
in meinem eigenen unternehmen
beschäftigen
respekt ist distanziert und kalt ich
denke es braucht mehr
natürlich ist die art von liebe die sie
erwähnten die schönheit der natur ein
ausgangspunkt solche empfindungen müssen
mit kraftvollen bildern der
gerechtigkeit verknüpft werden denken
sie an einige reden von martin luther
king
er verstand ist genial die liebe der
amerikaner zur schönen natur ihres
landes aufzugreifen und mit idealen der
freiheit und geschwisterlichkeit zu
verbinden
lasst freiheit von allen hügeln
georgiers erschallen
das müsst ihr erschien diesen schritt
muss man machen
angst kann dabei sogar dienlich sein
wenn man sich vor wirklich schlimmen
dingen fürchtet zum beispiel vor der
globalen erwärmung oder vor ökologischen
katastrophen
das sind gute ängste sie betrachten eine
wunderschöne landschaft und denken wie
schrecklich ich habe angst dass auf
diesem schönen weißen bergen bald kein
schnee mehr liegt diese angst wäre sie
nützlich was ich lehrer und politiker
fragen müssen wie kann man liebe und
diese angst mit den richtigen zielen und
absichten verknüpfen
alle ängste gegen die muslime zu richten
scheint mir falsch das ist ja genau
eines der themen gewesen bei der
minarett-initiative die angst war damals
zwar noch nicht so aktuell aber die
angst vor dem terror miliz die wir
natürlich jetzt sehr sehr viel
diskutiert würden sie sagen diese angst
ist real und darf die politik auf darauf
reagieren
natürlich ist der terrorismus ein
gewaltiges sehr reales problem aber ihn
mit religion zu verknüpfen ist ein
fehler
australiens premierminister sagt in den
nachrichten treffend ich will nicht vom
islam exchange sprechen denn es geht
weder um den islam noch um einen staat
sondern um eine horde krimineller
ich finde das stimmt kriminelle können
natürlich eine religion missbrauchen um
ihre ziele zu rechtfertigen und leute zu
rekrutieren
ähnlich handelte anders breivik im namen
der christlichen religion aber niemand
denkt weil brevik ein christ ist sei das
christentum schlecht wir kennen das
christentum und wissen dass es für ganz
andere werte steht aber die meisten
wissen nicht viel über den islam und
wofür dieser steht er wurde in der
schule nicht mehr an
deshalb meinen sie der islamische staat
präsentiere den islam
das stimmt nicht wir müssen also viel
lernen und zu verstehen versuchen wie
die welt aus der sicht andersdenkender
aussieht überdies sollten wir bedenken
dass die meisten muslime in zwei gut
florierenden demokratien leben nämlich
in indonesien und indien
millionen von muslimen die ein
friedliches und demokratisches leben
führen warum schauen wir nicht auf sie
und auf die vielen muslimischen
immigranten in ländern auf der ganzen
welt die friedlich und demokratisch
liegen
ich habe nichts gegen eine vernünftige
sicherheitspolitik die brauchen wir zum
glück werden wir an flughäfen gescannt
obwohl es unangenehm ist
aber man darf nicht unfair gegen eine
gruppe vorgehen und sie dämonisieren
ja aber in indien wird jeder mit einem
ganzkörper scanner kontrolliert
die frauen werden in einer kabine von
einer frau durchleuchtet und die männer
in einer anderen kabine von einem mann
von mir aus könnte man das auch bei uns
machen
das wäre eine gute sicherheitsmaßnahme
aber mir missfällt wenn menschen nur das
kennt werden weil ihre religiöse
kleidung auf ablehnung stößt in chicago
ist es im winter oft erheblich kälter
als viele ort hier und der wind kann
frostbeulen auf den lippen wohnte den
augen und auf der nase verursacht
wenn ich nach draußen gehe ziehe ich
deshalb einen bodenlangen schweren
mantel an entwickler einen schal um mund
und nase ich setze eine dicke brille auf
durch die man meine augen nicht sieht
ich ziehe mir eine mütze tief ins
gesicht und stellt die kapuze drüber ich
bin also mehr verhüllt als eine
burkaträgerin wenn meine augen sieht man
nicht niemand schaut mich schief dann
niemand sagt sie können diesen laden
nicht betreten
sie können sich so nicht in der
öffentlichkeit zeigen oder zum
unterricht gehen
natürlich würde man mich am flughafen
auffordern das alles auszuziehen zu
recht was ich beanstande ist dass die
burka in europa anders als man eher
winterkleidung als verdächtig gilt und
illegal ist und das nur weil die leute
finden es sei eine muslimische
bekleidung
ich verstehe ihren punkt und
gleichzeitig würde ich sagen es gibt
doch auch so etwas wie ein empfinden
dass man es beispielsweise nicht
besonders anständig findet wenn man mit
jemandem einen kaffee sitzt und er hat
die ganze zeit die sonnenbrille auf
sondern im normalen austausch sind ja
eigentlich gewohnt dass es ein gebot der
höflichkeit ist sein gesicht nicht zu
bedecken wir wollen die augen sehen wir
miteinander sprechen also diese
irritation die kann ich zumindest
nachvollziehen
wobei sie die augen einer burkaträgerin
sehen können
die augen sind tatsächlich das
kommunikativste im gesicht doch
bekanntlich können zum beispiel blinde
mit uns nicht über die augen kontakt
aufnehmen trotzdem können wir dank der
stimme mit ihnen kommunizieren
früher konnten blinde keine geschworenen
seien und sie durften weder anwalt noch
richter werden da man mit ihnen keinen
blickkontakt haben konnte wurden sie
nicht ernst genommen
heute denkt niemand mehr so mit einer
burkaträgerin können wir über die augen
und die stimme in kontakt treten
die kommunikation ist also sogar besser
möglich als mit einem blind
es ist nur ungewohnt mit allem was neu
ist haben wir mühe
doch das ist unser problem nicht das der
anderen die auch die augen betreffen
aber nicht vollständig nicht so sehr wie
eine starke sonnenbrille denn diese
frauen müssen ja etwas sehen können wie
auch immer durch das gitter der burka
kann man hindurch sehen
anders als durch verspiegelte
sonnenbrillen die viele skifahrer als
schutz vor der sonne tragen durch die
burka sie kann die augen
sie sind eine berühmte professorin für
philosophie jetzt an der universität in
chicago und der feminismus waren auch
immer ein anliegen die rechte der frauen
und im zusammenhang mit der burka mit
dem kopftuch wurde das ja auch sehr auf
diskutiert hat man gesagt na ja das ist
eine unterdrückung der frau diese frauen
wollen dieses kleidungsstück gar nicht
tragen
das ist ein argument dass sie nicht
akzeptieren warum nicht als feministin
bin ich sehr kritisch gegenüber sozialen
verhaltensweisen die frauen zu objekten
oder zur ware degradieren feministinnen
kennen schon lange den begriff der
objektiver zion die sagen dass frauen
wie eine sache behandelt werden
wenn leute also sagen die burka
degradiere frauen zu objekten erinnert
mich das an die 80er jahre
damals sprachen alle über pornographie
und über werbung die nackte frauen als
austauschbare körper zeit durch all das
würden frauen zu objekten oder zur ware
degradiert kann man argumentieren soll
das alles verboten werden
darüber muss man nachdenken ich denke es
wäre ein verstoß gegen eine
freiheitliche gesellschaftsordnung alles
für illegal zu erklären was frauen wie
eine ware behandelt wir müssten fast
alles verbieten was im fernsehen gezeigt
wird und die ganze pornografie
ich denke die beste haltung dazu ist
eine freie meinungsäußerung die aber
kritik zulässt wenn wir über die burka
reden müssen wir auch über diese dinge
sprechen was es zum beispiel mit der
schönheitschirurgie
immer wenn ich mich im fitnessstudio
umkleide fallen mir frauen auf mit
narben von bauch straffungen oder
fettabsaugungen damit vermarkten sich
frauen und degradieren sich selbst zur
wahl
ich finde nicht dass sollte illegal
seien
es ist traurig dass ich eine frau ihren
bauch straffen lassen muss um einen mann
zu finden der sie liebt aber ich bin
eine vertreterin der freiheit
natürlich gibt es viele verhaltensweisen
die frauen zu objekten oder waren
degradieren
ja die burka wirklich dazu nun wenn eine
frau bedroht wird oder dazu gezwungen
wird die burka zu tragen sollte das
gesetz angreifen
häusliche gewalt ist illegal in solchen
fällen muss die polizei eingreifen und
zwar viel öfter als sie das tut aber in
europa und nordamerika wird die
islamische kleidung meist freiwillig
getragen nicht aus zwang
es handelt sich also nicht um häusliche
gewalt andernfalls muss man dagegen
vorgehen das ist klar
das problem der häuslichen gewalt ist
immens
es ist eng verknüpft mit
alkoholmissbrauch in einer
praktizierenden muslimischen familie
sollte es also eigentlich weniger
häusliche gewalt geben
wir haben keine diesbezüglichen
untersuchungen aber davon gehe ich aus
sie wären auch eine sehr sehr gute
politikerin auch die argumente die sie
dringen und wie sie sind verknüpfen mit
dem der gegebenheiten wie wir sie
vorfinden in der welt da draußen
sie sage ich auch immer wieder eines
ihrer philosophischen vorbilder ist john
stuart mill
der britische philosoph aus dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert und er war ja
wissenschaftler philosoph und
gleichzeitig parlamentarier haben sie je
mit einer politischen karriere lieber
zuerst möchte ich sagen mir hatte keine
wahl als atheist bekam er keine
akademische anstellung zu seiner zeit
musste man der amerikanischen kirche
angehören und an die 39 artikel der
church of england glauben um in oxford
oder cambridge klären zu können um zu
überleben
für die british east india company er
ging erst später in die politik
er wäre wohl gerne akademiker geworden
dann hätte er mehr bücher geschrieben
ich schätze mich sehr glücklich dass ich
meine tage frei einteilen und mich mit
wunderbaren kollegen und freunden
austauschen kann die meine arbeit
schätzen
ich habe tolle studenten die mein leben
bereichern und deren leben ich
hoffentlich auch irgendwie bereiche zur
politik fühlte ich mich hingezogen
dafür braucht es einen bestimmten
persönlichkeitstyp der ich nicht bin
ich lasse mich schnell verunsichern
ich reagiere sehr sensibel auf kritik
nicht in meiner arbeit da bin ich froh
darum
wenn mir aber jemand auf persönlicher
ebene sagt ich benehme mich schlecht mag
ich das gar nicht wenn ich jemanden
entlassen müsste zum beispiel in meinem
büro das wäre undenkbar für mich deshalb
will ich nicht dekanen werden
denn ich müsste womöglich leute
entlassen die das dann daneben fänden
und mich kritisierten dann könnte ich
nicht mehr schlafen so bin ich wenn ich
denke ich habe jemanden verletzt kann
ich nicht schlafen
so dürfen politiker nicht sein sie
würden zusammenbrechen ich glaube nicht
ich bin eine person die sich schnell
schuldig fühlt warum fühle ich mich
schuldig wenn ich jemanden verletzt habe
das kommt von meiner familie aus meiner
kindheit ein wenig verstehe ich es ja
auch immer ich fühle mich zu schnell
schuldig und gehöre deshalb nicht in die
politik auch nicht in die administration
einer universität
ich habe ein paar administrative
aufgaben ich bin zum beispiel in
gewissen kommissionen auch in einigen
wichtigen aber dekanin oder sogar
vorsteherin einer universität wollte ich
nie werden noch weniger gehörig in die
politik das ist ein schreckliches leben
man muss eine dicke haut haben wie kann
man die liebe von der ich spreche
bewahren und sich die dicke haut zulegen
die es in der politik braucht das finde
ich sehr schwierig wenn ich an leute wie
barack obama denke der in chicago mein
kollege war er tut sich wohl schwer
damit er reagiert mit rückzug
das ist nicht toll er unterrichtete an
der hochschule für rechtswissenschaft
wenn auch nur teilzeit denn er war
abgeordneter von illinois war also nicht
die ganze woche dort wir besuchten das
gleiche fitnessstudio
dort begegnete ich manchmal und wir
unterhielten uns während wir unsere
gewichts übungen machten das team kommt
immer wieder vor in unserem gespräch und
ich weiß auch sie machen ja sehr sehr
viel sport welche sportarten betreiben
sie eigentlich
vor allem langstreckenlauf ich
absolviere wenn möglich einen oder zwei
halbmarathons pro jahr
ich renne sehr gern in einem gewissen
alter muss man darauf achten dass man
gesund bleibt und keine knieprobleme
bekommt deshalb mache ich auch gewichts
training unglaubliche disziplin die sie
an den tag legen sie sie sprechen auch
unglaublich viele sprachen sie brauchen
keine übersetzung für dieses gespräch
unterhalten uns einfach so erstaunlich
was sie alles beherrschen sie sind auch
sängerin klassische ja das ist mein
lieblingshobby doch das kann ich
natürlich nicht ausüben wenn ich
unterwegs bin
opernarien wenn ich zu hause bin trete
ich manchmal gemeinsam mit den anderen
schülern meines lehrers aus ich singe
auch in meinem jüdischen tempel
denn dort legt man großen wert auf e
musik ja das mag ich das bereitet mir
viel freude
sie sind ja zum judentum übergetreten
als sie das erste mal geheiratet haben
und haben erst vor ein paar jahren ihre
bat mitzwa erhalten das heißt sie sind
auch jetzt im tempel ihr wissen aus der
thora was bedeutet ihnen persönlich ihre
religion das judentum inspirierte mich
zunächst wegen seines engagements für
die gerechtigkeit in unserer welt ich
konvertierte als ich heiratete
natürlich war die familie meines mannes
erfreut darüber und seine großmutter
akzeptierte mich besser aber das
judentum hat mich schon vorher
interessiert denn ich realisierte wie
sehr vor allem das reform judentum in
den usa auf soziale gerechtigkeit
ausgerichtet ist diese richtung des
judentums stellt das moral gesetz ins
zentrum
alles andere ist freiwillig auch die
essens regeln und sonstige rituale nicht
freiwillig ist die gerechtigkeit dafür
müssen wir kämpfen
warum brauchen wir eine religion um für
gerechtigkeit zu kämpfen fragen sie
vielleicht
hunt hatte dafür die richtige antwort
weil wir schwach sind und eine
gemeinschaft brauchen die uns hilft das
moral gesetz einzuhalten
mein tempel hat den größten garten der
usa in dem gemüse für die armen angebaut
wird
das ist eine unserer tätigkeiten und wir
tun noch nie aber ich liebe auch musik
sie ist für mich eng verknüpft mit dem
engagement für ideale wie die
gerechtigkeit
ich gehe oft in den tempel um zu singen
wir haben viele musikalische aktivitäten
ich habe die sogenannte kann die nation
die traditionelle jüdische rezitation
gelernt dinge aber auch moderne musik
denn die juden lebten überall in europa
sowie es christliche musik aus dem 18 19
jahrhundert gibt gibt es auch jüdische
musik aus der gleichen zeit
wir haben eben einen neuen kantor
angestellt die experte der jüdischen
musik aus dem berlin des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts ist wir sind also sehr viel
interessanter musik sprechen wir über
das thema gerechtigkeit das sich wie ein
roter faden durch ihr leben durch zieht
sie haben ja schon am anfang davon
gesprochen dass sie mit matthias henn
zusammen eigentlich fast eine neue
gerechtigkeit theorie entworfen haben
den sogenannten capabilities abrutschten
fähigkeiten ansatz der auch in vielen
uno programmen dann niederschlag
gefunden hat und einer der dreh und
angelpunkte darin ist dass sie
eigentlich aristoteles in die modernen
gerechtigkeits theorien rein gebracht
haben
was hat aristoteles in der heutigen
sozialdemokratie ihrer meinung nach zu
suchen was daran natürlich befasste ich
mich schon mit aristoteles bevor ich
matthias n kennenlernte
und er hat den fähigkeiten ansatz
teilweise aus gearbeitet bevor er über
aristoteles nachdachte aus einer
gewissen distanz bericht sagen dass
seine ideen von aristoteles beeinflusst
waren aber sehr indirekt das
marxistische humanistischer umfeld in
dem er in indien aufwuchs war davon
geprägt weil der junge marx von
aristoteles beeinflusst war
worin bestand nun dieser einfluss es war
die idee dass es für ein
menschenwürdiges leben
eine gewisse politische struktur braucht
die es im kapitalismus des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts nicht gab
da der kapitalismus die menschen daran
hindert die ganze fülle ihrer
menschlichen fähigkeiten zu nutzen
das war für mich die erste verbindung
zwischen aristoteles und der modernen
politik und auch für amadea obwohl er
aristoteles nicht erwähnte es geht darum
nicht nur auf das wirtschaftswachstum
und die dinge zu setzen die der
kapitalismus gut abdeckt wir müssen
vielmehr die menschen berücksichtigen
und schauen ob der wirtschaftliche
fortschritt ihr leben verbessert und
inwiefern er sie in ihrem tun und seien
befähigt das muss unser wichtigster
fokus sein
die frage des wirtschaftswachstums
sollte zweitrangig sein
mattia sieht darin vor allem eine neue
möglichkeit gesellschaften miteinander
zu vergleichen
ich fand wir könnten einen schritt
weiter gehen und eine minimale
gerechtigkeit theorie formulieren was
muss eine gerechte gesellschaft in
menschen als minimum geben damit sie den
namen gerecht verdient wir verfolgen
also nicht die gleichen projekte gehen
aber vom gleichen fähigkeiten ansatz aus
von der frage inwiefern werden menschen
wirklich befähigt diese arbeit
zusammenfasst da geht es ja außer eben
genau um diesen punkt dass es eben nicht
mehr der wohlstand sozusagen in form des
bruttoinlandproduktes angeben sollte
über eine gesellschaft gerecht ist ob es
ihr gut geht ob sie entwickelt ist
sondern die lebensqualität der menschen
und da sagen sie es geht um eine
substanzielle theorie des guten lebens
und damit haben sie eigentlich einen
entwurf gemacht ein stück weit auch
immer john rawls kritisiert hat sie sind
ja auch eine schülerin von john rawls
aber sie haben immer gesagt ich stehe es
stehen zwar in der tradition des
politischen liberalismus und trotzdem
gibt es eine abweichung nämlich dass es
irgendwie um eine theorie des guten
gehen muss der staat muss also doch
nicht ganz neutral sein bezüglich dessen
ein gutes leben ausmacht wie genau darf
denn der start da eingreifen in
vielerlei hinsicht stimme ich mit rolls
überein
ich finde seine theorie der
gerechtigkeit überzeugend ich denke sie
antwortet auch viele probleme welche die
meisten bürger haben
sie enthält zudem eine interessante
abhandlung über politische freiheit und
über wirtschaftliche umverteilung sehr
ansprechend finde ich als idee des
politischen liberalismus erfordert das
politische prinzipien nicht zu eng
gefasst werden damit die menschen genug
raum haben um ihr eigenes leben zu leben
diesbezüglich stimme ich mit ihm überein
für mich greift aber seine theorie zu
kurz bei menschen mit schweren
behinderungen und beim grundsätzlicheren
thema der macht asymmetrie so zieht er
gerechtigkeit für tiere gar nicht in
betracht denn für ihn sind einkommen und
vermögen als weg mittel als bräuchte es
nur sie damit die gesellschaft
funktioniert aber wenn man behinderten
menschen ein qualitativ hochstehendes
leben ermöglichen will helfen einkommen
und vermögen allein nicht weiter
außer man entwirft eine
gesellschaftsform die behinderte voll
und ganz integriert mit einer neuen
ausbildungspolitik und neuen ideen wie
man städte gestaltet damit menschen sich
wirklich von einem ort zum anderen
bewegen können
auch das hatte matthias henn
thematisiert man könnte einen
behinderten im rollstuhl das gleiche
einkommen und vermögen geben wie
jemandem der nicht auf den rollstuhl
angewiesen ist
aber wer gehen kann kommt in der
gesellschaft viel weiter denn diese ist
für nicht behinderte geschaffen
wer auf den rollstuhl angewiesen ist ist
nicht gleichermaßen befähigt er kann
nicht die gleichen dinge tun
man muss also über befähigung nachdenken
statt über einkommen und vermögen wenn
man die probleme behinderter wirklich
angehen will
bewegung ist auch wichtig wenn man
tieren gewisse rechte zugestehen will
was können tiere schon mit vermögen
anfangen sie brauchen respekt für ihre
fähigkeit ein erfüllendes florierendes
leben zu führen
man kann die mängel der
nahrungsmittelindustrie nur auf decken
wenn man über die fähigkeiten statt über
das einkommen von tieren nachdenkt
eigentlich den gefühlen stück weit weil
sie nämlich auch sagen ein volles
blühendes gutes schönes leben was
menschen haben sollten in einer
gerechten gesellschaft was beinhaltet
auch gefühle
es gehört zur menschlichen leben dazu
dass wir fühlen gewesen sind dass wir
freude empfinden können das wir lieben
das wir vertrauen aber auch dass ihr
traurig sein können wäre ein leben nicht
besser indem ihr nicht traurig sein
müssen
nein sicher nicht
ein leben ohne trauer und leid wäre ein
leben in dem man niemanden liebt wenn
sie nicht in der glücklichen lage sind
unsterbliche eltern zu haben werden sie
vielleicht in ihrem leben erfahren
mein buch über gefühle ab hebel sofort
beginnt mit meiner reaktion auf den tod
meiner mutter
wenn ich denke jeder leser hat schon mal
um jemanden getrauert wenn nicht um die
eltern dann um die großeltern
wir trauern weil wir sterblich sind und
geliebte menschen älter werden
das gehört zum leben und dem können wir
nur ausweichen wenn wir niemanden lieben
es ist ganz wichtig dass wir an unseren
emotionen arbeiten dass wir ein stück
weit unsere gefühle kultivieren dass wir
sie wieder spüren lernen aber auch dass
wir sie ins positive wenden eben auch um
die gerechtigkeit zur beförderung ein
stück weit und unser leben gut zu machen
ein beispiel mit dem sie denken man kann
das erreichen ist eben in dem die ropal
hören
in diesem buch politische emotionen ist
ein ganzes kapitel eigentlich eine ganz
minutiöse analyse von le nozze di figaro
die hochzeit des figaro von mozart sie
sagen dass die figur des ruins
in einer neuen art und weise liebt und
dass sie diese liebe eigentlich sowie
als modell liebe sehen für eine neue
gesellschaft was glauben sie können wir
lernen denn der opa besuchen kann man
ins opernhaus sitzen sich ein öl anhören
und dann hat man in wie ich weiß nicht
neue ideen bezüglich von gefühl ich
verwende die hochzeit des figaro wie
eine art philosophischen text
philosophische texte müssen ja nicht
immer nur aus worten bestehen hier sind
es worte und musik
damit will ich nicht sagen dass alle in
die oper gehen sollen
ich liebe opern und ich denke für leute
mit musikalischer ausbildung sind opern
großartig denn da geht es nur um
emotionen
das ist die grundlage einer oper und sie
umfasst so viele künste das bühnenbild
den gesang die körpersprache die
schauspielkunst
es ist also eine sehr ausdrucksstarke
kunstform die gefühle aus aber die
meisten leute in unserer modernen
gesellschaft gehen nicht in die oper die
popmusik ist so gesehen viel wichtiger
auf seinem marsch auf washington nutzte
martin luther king junior nicht
opernmusik sondern die traditionelle
musik der afroamerikaner nämlich spirit
wars das brachte die menschen zusammen
im politischen projekt das mir
vorschwebt sollten wir den fokus auf
populäre musik setzen es ist ein
musikvideo das innert kürze unglaublich
viele klicks erhalten hat mittlerweile
ist es auf youtube 730 millionen mal
angespielt werden
[Musik]
juni bis juli
märz
[Musik]
730 millionen mal sie müssen machen wir
das sehr angesehen bereits ich habe sie
noch nie gesehen aber sie beeindruckt
mich nicht ich finde sie sehr
narzisstisch sicher weckt sie keine
gefühle der geschwisterlichkeit oder
nächstenliebe nicht wegen des songs ich
finde in jedem musikform kann man gute
oder schlechte gefühle kultivieren
da ist die oper keine ausnahme wie wir
wissen kultiviert der wagner in seinen
opern viele schlechte gefühle
das ist ein komplizierter fall aber ich
denke es ist schon so die heutigen
popmusik fokussiert nicht wie der spirit
of soziale gerechtigkeit
die tour war deshalb geschaffen worden
aus der not der menschen die einander
brauchten weil sie unter der sklaverei
litten und sich davon befreien wollen
aber auch heutigen popmusik kann
gerechtigkeit fördern
matthiasson kabir der sich im sequel
nennt ist der hip hop künstler und
leitet die musikabteilung einer
großartigen schule in boston mit seiner
hiphop kunst setzt er sich gegen
sexismus und für gewaltlosigkeit und
weltfrieden ein
seine cd wird vielleicht nicht so oft
gehört wie die von miley cyrus
aber sie ist sie erfolgreich sie heißt
piece for solutions und er reist die
neuengland herum und hält vorträge über
hiphop als medium für gewaltfreiheit und
gegen sexismus solche künstler gehen mir
hoffnung und davon gibt es viele ein
sehr genaues bild davon wie genau diese
musik beschaffen sein soll oder nicht
unbedingt die musik sondern die texte
die art und weise wie das die emotionen
transportiert die sie fördern wollen
das heißt es scheint für sie schon
emotion oder gefühle zu geben die uns
irgendwie weiter bringen in diesem
projekt der menschlichkeit oder der
gerechtigkeit verstehe ich das richtig
ja das ist richtig alle kunstrichtungen
haben die macht
gefühle zu fördern die uns weiterbringen
ich denke die visuellen künste sind
besonders wichtig wenn es kulturen und
öffentliche monumente befinden sich oft
an orten wo sich menschen begegnen
bei der musik ist es schwieriger denn
beim hören sind viele in ihrer eigenen
welt gefangen
vor allem heute wo alle mit kopfhörern
herumlaufen und die anderen menschen
kann nicht beachten wenn aber jemand
eine neue gedenkstätte errichtet wird
sie von menschen besucht es kommt zu
begegnungen und gemeinsamen erlebnissen
und ich finde das ist eine sehr
wertvolle erfahrung in meinem buch
schreibe ich ausführlich über
verschiedene gedenkstätten wie das
vietnam veteranen oder das lincoln
memorial
aber auch über parks wie den central
park er wurde gemacht als ort wo arme
und reiche menschen die schönheit der
natur am gleichen ort erleben können
ich denke landschaftsarchitektur ist
eine sehr wertvolle kunstform die wir
anerkennen und wertschätzen sollten sie
weckt viele gefühle in uns ohne dass wir
uns dessen bewusst sind
wenn ihr konkreter werden es gibt dieses
große gerechtigkeit projekt von ihnen
menschen sollen ein gutes leben führen
können gemäß dem was sie aus menschen
auszeichnet war somit gefühlen
mitspielen mit den grundbedürfnissen
aber eben auch darüber hinaus ihrer
kultur gemäss das ist das projekt die
gefühle sind das vehikel dazu ein stück
weit brauchen ja auch gefühle sowohl in
unserem leben aber auch um die recht
gerechtigkeit voranzubringen
nehmen wir ein beispiel von massiver
ungerechtigkeit sie haben chef selber
schon erwähnt die rassenunruhen in den
usa die gerade die daumen hoch kochen
sind diskriminierung die leider immer
noch an der tagesordnung ist wir denken
an die unruhen in ferguson aber auch in
new york im moment wenn wir ganz konkret
werden was heißt das für sie wie können
die mit gefühlen diese probleme lösen
die kann die politik mit gefühlen jetzt
vorgehen konkret als erstes müssen wir
uns mit der frage auseinandersetzen was
ist die rolle die wut
viele leute finden wird sei sehr
konstruktiv und helfe gegen
ungerechtigkeit zu kämpfen
ich war selber auch dieser ansicht
aber in den einstein vorlesungen die ich
momentan halte und nächstes jahr als
buch publiziere argumentiere ich dass
das nicht stimmt wut ist ein
irreführendes gefühl aus dem heraus wir
anderen menschen leid zufügen
anstatt ein konstruktives projekt zu
verfolgen das hoffnung vermittelt ich
denke martin luther king junior verstand
dass menschen oft zuerst durch ihre wut
motiviert sind einer protestbewegung
beizutreten
das ist in ordnung aber wenn sie einmal
dabei sind müssen sie ihre wut
überwinden
sonst hindert sie diese daran vorwärts
zu schauen und auf eine zukunft
hinzuwirken in der alle gemeinsam
vorwärtsgehen ich untersuchte also drei
große protestbewegungen die sich nicht
von der wut leiten ließen die von gandhi
die von luther king und die von nelson
mandela in afrika sie agierten ohne wut
aber nicht alle gewaltlos mandela war
bereit an einem gewissen punkt gewalt
einzusetzen
king sagte gewalt als selbstverteidigung
sei in ordnung aber er wolle in dem
moment keine gewalt anwenden
nur gandhi war absoluter gewaltlosigkeit
verpflichtet aber alle drei handelten
nicht aus der wut heraus denn sie
wussten wut bringt uns nicht weiter
was wir brauchen sind konstruktive
emotionen wie hoffnung und engagement
gepaart mit geschwisterlicher liebe um
von der mut zur liebe zu gelangen muss
man die tat von der person trennen
man kann sagen die tat ist widerwärtig
und falsch aber man muss verstehen
lernen dass der täter nicht schlecht ist
sondern ein mitmensch der trotzdem
lebenswert ist in der hoffnung dass er
merkt dass er einen fehler gemacht hat
gibt es nicht momente wo man einfach
fragen muss wut ist angebracht um nicht
nur im sinne von angebracht das erste
emotion und ich
ob sie dann überwinden sondern es ist
dermaßen anstößig dass wir mit wut
vorgehen wollen
was ich in diesem neuen projekt sage ist
kontrovers und ich habe hatte nicht alle
davon überzeugen zu können
mich hat es jedenfalls überzeugt früher
dachte ich anders wenn sie meine
früheren bücher lesen sehen sie das so
war auf meiner liste der fähigkeiten
habe ich die wut als eine gute fähigkeit
verteidigt einige befreundete
feministinnen haben mich dazu überredet
sie sagten du hast die wut weggelassen
das tat ich weil ich persönlich wut
nicht mag und zu vermeiden suche aber
ich dachte womöglich liege ich falsch
ich fügte sie also hinzu weil es mir
nahegelegt wurde
inzwischen bin ich zum schluss gelangt
dass ich recht hatte und wut sehr
destruktiv ist mal sehen ob ich die
leute überzeugen kann
denken sie mal an die scheidung
dieses phänomen ist in der modernen
gesellschaft fast allgegenwärtig haben
menschen so sehr das bedürfnis den
ehemaligen partner leid zuzufügen oder
ihm alles erdenklich schlimme zu
wünschen
ich finde das ist eine falle
die wut hindert sie daran etwas
konstruktives zu tun und weiterzugehen
was bringt es zu denken ich hoffe mein
ex mann hat ein schreckliches leben mit
seiner neuen frau da tut man doch besser
etwas gutes für die welt oder für sich
selber sei es dass man einem hobby
nachgeht oder mit einer freundin in
restaurant aufsucht wir sollten positive
und konstruktive lösungen finden
zu sehen am anfang steht möglicherweise
die wut und die kann ja auch sehr gesund
sein weil es eine form von distanz gibt
und einem auch hilft diese distanz zu
gewinnen die man gewinnen muss wenn man
verlassen das mag für manche situationen
zu treffen
mut hat tatsächlich einen begrenzten
nutzen als übergang zu anderen gefühlen
sie sagten interessanterweise wut
schaffe distanz oft tut sie das nämlich
nicht wenn man sich ständig auf die wut
gegen eine person konzentriert bindet
man sich an diese person anstatt sich
von ihr zu lösen
viel besser wäre es ins fitnessstudio
oder in die oper zu gehen anstatt sich
mit dieser person zu befassen
sie selber haben wir auch massive
diskriminierung erlebt sie erzählen an
einer stelle die sie als erste frau
fälle wurden an der elite universität in
harvard und einer der kollegen hat
vorgeschlagen barcelona für männer
gedacht sei man könnte ihnen ja den
titel het hergeben was gleichbedeutend
ist mit prostituierte im alten
griechenland kann sie sich nicht
erinnern dass ich unglaublich wütend
wurden in diesem moment ich war
tatsächlich ziemlich wütend ich denke wo
kann ein nützliches signal sein
ein hinweis dass etwas schrecklich
falsch ist ich wurde von einem liebenden
respektvollen vater erzogen und war
deshalb nicht darauf vorbereitet dass
ich als frau irgendwelche probleme haben
könnte
das hatte ich nicht erwartet etwas gutes
kann wut tatsächlich bewirken
sie gibt uns ein signal sie alarmiert
uns hier ist etwas nicht in ordnung aber
dann sollte man sich nicht einfach in
seiner wut schulen sondern fragen was
mache ich nun damit meine reaktion war
dass ich mich noch mehr einsetzte und
versuchte noch besser zu arbeiten und
natürlich hätte ich mich an meine
wertvollen freunde denn ich hatte glück
es gab zwar leute an der universität wie
diesen älteren altphilologie professor
aber ich bekam auch starker
unterstützung von philosophen wie
bernard williams ständig und john rawls
ich hatte wirklich glück denn auch sie
gab es in meinem leben
warum hätte ich mich vom schlechten witz
dieses dummen mannes aufhalten
wir sind bereits am ende unseres
gesprächs mir fällt ein dass der
philosoph jean-jacques hohen in einer
wunderbaren rezession ihres buches sein
ist etwas geschrieben hat die
gerechtigkeit ist hart ein schwieriges
projekt und genau deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass das projekt eben wie unsere
gefühle mit einbezieht wie das genau
geschehen soll darüber haben sie viel
geforscht
ich denke es ist ein wichtiges thema
aber dass noch viel gesprochen wird und
ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich martha
nussbaum
ich danke ihnen ich habe das gespräch
sehr genossen
[Musik]